en fait cette montre vous l'aviez pu
combien de temps je l'avais à peu près
depuis un an plus ou moins
voilà je l'avais depuis un an et du coup
voilà comme ça moi je suis responsable
en menuiserie dans l'événementiel quoi
donc je sais que vous avez économisé
beaucoup d'argent pour pas mal de
déplacements
vous êtes fans de montrer on le comprend
et vous êtes dit je vais me faire mon
kif je vais m'acheter je vais m'acheter
cette montre tout à fait vous pouvez
nous dire à peu près combien elle va
aller cette montre ou pas à peu près
12000 euros c'est ça c'est une très
belle montre et voilà si on a le droit
d'avoir des rêves et vous avez travaillé
pour ça vous avez mis de côté ou c'était
et vous vouliez payer votre mariage avec
cette montre en fait exactement donc en
fait au moment que je l'ai acheté j'ai
tout je me suis dit dans ma tête en fait
c'est comme un placement à la banque
c'est ça qui voulait en fait c'est comme
un placement à la banque et vous avez
raison c'est du coup en fait ça a été
clairement
bon bien entendu tout augmente donc le
mariage relativement de l'argent voilà
du coup en fait j'ai décidé de la vendre
relativement à contrecoeur parce que
c'est un modèle qui était fin que je
voulais depuis des années parce que en
plus j'ai réussi à avoir l'année de 1995
donc ma naissance mon année de naissance
donc oui c'était
donc de poster une annonce sur leboncoin
écoutez bien cette histoire incroyable
vous avez l'habitude de vendre des
choses sur ce site enfin comme un peu
tout le monde quoi enfin vous la mettez
à combien la montre
vous aviez plusieurs contacts tout de
suite oui bien sûr oui oui donc là un
homme vous envoie un message et échange
son numéro de téléphone avec vous
exactement vous êtes appelés oui oui il
m'a demandé mon téléphone il m'a appelé
c'est ce que j'ai dit en fait le courant
au téléphone est très bien passé en fait
il y a eu vraiment
enfin c'était un coup de fil on va dire
standard quoi il y avait vraiment quand
il vous demandait
des informations sur la France bien
entendu mes disponibilités tout ça il
avait l'air calé en montre
il s'y connaît oui ils s'y connaissait
quand même un petit pose beaucoup de
questions normales
aussi on se dit tout à fait il faut être
en confiance donc on est dans
rendez-vous donc vous vous voyez où
c'est vous c'est vous qui donnez
rendez-vous c'est lui en fait dans un
premier temps il me dit que il veut
venir chez moi d'accord moi de base je
voulais faire la vente chez moi et du
coup il me dit qu'au final il est obligé
d'annuler parce que il a pas trop le
temps il a repris il est un peu pris au
travail tout ça donc de ce fait
on décale le rendez-vous en fait au
dimanche et moi j'ai dit au final que ça
m'arrangeait car en fait le dimanche
c'était le baptême de mon neveu d'accord
donc on a fait la entre guillemets la
vente parce que au final il y a pas eu
de vente mais la vente en fait quasi
devant la salle à 20 m de la salle donc
la selle est en contrebas et la mairie
un petit peu plus haut si vous voulez
alors vous lui demandez même une
photocopie de sa carte d'identité
exactement et du coup
il me l'envoie pas donc il me dit pour
des soucis de sécurité je préfère que
on remplisse tous les papiers en main
propre en fait c'est un gage de pour lui
comme pour moi quoi d'accord donc
premier rendez-vous annulé voilà
pourquoi il dit qu'il est qu'il est pris
par le travail
deuxième rendez-vous c'est donc dimanche
dernier vous lui donnez comme vous
l'avez dit rendez-vous sur la place de
la mairie
dans un village en Isère qui compte
environ 2000 habitants vous vouliez
absolument le rencontrer dans un lieu
public pour il y avait des gens autour
ou pas oui bah après enfin c'est un
petit village vous savez c'est très fin
moi je me suis sentie sécurité vu qu'il
y avait quand même du monde avec moi je
me suis dit voilà
enfin j'aurais jamais pensé à ça
honnêtement j'ai peut-être été bête de
pas vous allez nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé après vous allez voir c'est
mais du coup en fait oui je m'attendais
pas pour moi j'avais pris mes
précautions en disant bah mon père de
venir et à mon beau-frère et après sous
un confort circonstances il a dû rentrer
mais voilà donc c'est le baptême de
votre petit neveu comme on nous le dites
vous quitter l'événement juste pour la
vente vous vous rendez à la vente donc
avec votre père et votre beau-frère a dû
partir c'est voilà mon beau-frère en
fait moi je dis tout de suite mon
beau-frère il vient mon père il vient
comme ça j'ai dit enfin j'avais essayé
de prendre de garantie parce que voilà
il y avait quand même
c'est une énorme c'est un truc de fou
c'est une grosse transaction tout à fait
donc
on vient finalement avec votre papa qui
est avec nous exactement
là
l'acheteur arrive
voilà vous le voyez il arrive tout seul
oui non en fait quand il nous appelle
nous on sort de la salle il est déjà sur
place si vous voulez il dit qu'il est à
côté d'un Nissan Juke noir sauf que ce
n'était pas du tout son véhicule sauf
que ça en fait on s'en est pas rendu
compte sur le sur le fait quoi d'accord
donc on arrive on du coup je le salue
jusqu'à là-bas on va dire que tout se
passe bien
donc par la suite il vérifie quand même
que ça soit bien authentique qui vérifie
tous les numéros comme bah en fait elle
était en feuille et tout seul vous êtes
tout seul c'est à côté de sa voiture
vous êtes en fait c'était mis vraiment à
la mairie sur le sur le il y avait une
petite rebord pour enfin il y avait
beaucoup de monde autour à part votre
papa ou pas du tout bah après il y avait
des passants enfin sans plus voilà après
c'est comme je vous ai dit c'est un
petit un petit village de dimanche il y
avait pas non plus fou quoi donc là
il regarde la montre bien sûr voilà il
regarde le certificat d'authenticité
regarde s'il a monté dans bon état ou
pas si la boîte correspond bien enfin
tout il pendant il regarde tout quoi
vous aviez convenu du prix oui donc
12000 euros non il avait négocié un peu
lui il avait négocié à 11002 d'accord
11002 voilà d'accord
de 10000 euros et 1200 euros en cash
d'accord voilà donc
là il est intéressé par la montre oui
oui direct il me dit très bien oui bah
elle est vraiment belle tout ça je vous
la prends la au dernier moment il vous
demande de voir une dernière fois la
boîte voilà il me dit bah je pourrais
voir jusqu'à boite parce que vous savez
en fait il y a un numéro derrière la
boîte pour vérifier d'accord et il
apprend il regarde il dit bon bah très
bien à faire la vente j'ai cherché
l'argent ma voiture et il a pas le temps
de dire ça qui part en courant il part
en courant voilà d'accord il part donc
en fait la boîte il y avait tout
il y avait tous les papiers la boîte là
sur Boîte c'était vraiment
avec la boîte vous réagissez comment le
réflexe c'est je cours ah oui et je dis
à mon père il se barre avec le réflexe
je cours après lui hein clairement
normal voilà le réflexe que j'ai eu donc
vous mettez tout seul à le poursuivre
votre papa vient avec bien sûr mon père
je suis aussi donc là vous arrivez à le
rattraper oui mais enfin on a peiné
parce qu'en fait il a couru à fond
vraiment peut-être pendant 500 mètres
d'accord et en fait dans ma tête j'ai
dit sur le long terme je vais la voir
j'ai dit en fait j'ai essayé de
m'économiser quand je voyais qui
commençait à faiblir un peu bah là j'ai
tout donné et là vous arrivez à
l'attraper par la capuche je l'attrape
par la capuche ils se retourne il met un
coup de poing
donc le réflexe je le pousse par terre
d'accord et du coup entre-temps le
complice parce qu'il y avait un complice
il y avait un complice qui était
peut-être on va dire 100 mètres devant
qui était assis sur un banc mais ça en
fait quand on est parti il a crié et ils
sont il est parti en fait en ouvrant un
petit peu on l'avait d'accord sur le
coup en fait on l'a pas vu Xavier d'une
personne lambda dans la rue quoi donc là
il y a une deuxième personne qui arrive
voilà et du coup donc j'ai juste le
temps de me relever et là donc je reçois
un coup de bête de baseball en pleine
tête donc là c'est l'autre l'autre
l'autre Contis entre temps la personne
m'a quand même mis plusieurs coups de
poing au visage donc en fait je reçois
le coup de battes en pleine tête donc je
vous cache pas que bah ça fait très mal
déjà et que bah enfin
je suis pas tombé chaos tout de suite
enfin j'ai une grosse douleur donc je me
suis mis en bouche c'est un choc et là
en fait
ils sont parlés ils ont dit à
chef-le-hachevleux et là ils m'ont mis
plein de coups de pied visage abdomen
donc bah sur j'ai une entorse du genou
également de plusieurs contusions que
vous êtes bien embauché alors là votre
papa vous fait voilà vous assistez à la
scène non vu que ça monte au bout d'un
moment le cœur il a dit arrête toi parce
que tu vas péter donc j'ai avancé en
marchant et puis je souhaite appeler la
police
entre temps et puis ça faisait un angle
je les voyais plus et quand j'ai passé
l'angle ben je l'ai vu par terre et
l'autre qui lui tapait dessus j'ai
gueulé et ils sont partis
clairement il m'a sauvé la vie parce que
je pense que encore quelques coups et
franchement ça aurait pu être encore
pire quoi double fracture du nez
traumatisme crânien entorse du genou
on est quasiment une semaine après votre
agression
est-ce que vous avez l'identité des
voleurs pour l'instant non j'étais ce
matin la gendarmerie pour effectuer le
portrait-robot
qu'on est arrivé quand même relativement
à bien faire même si c'est des images
que j'ai plus trop envie de voir
clairement dans ma tête
un peu de racailles quoi c'est ce que
j'ai dit voilà concrètement voilà des
pour c’était des un peu type
nord-africain clairement un peu type
voilà type on va dire des petits
quartiers un petit peu leur quartier il
y a de tout dans le quartier
ça c'est voilà c'est voilà on va pas
demander une description ici on n'est
pas là pour faire un portrait-robot
juste vous les reconnaîtriez si vous les
revoyez tout à fait ah bah oui je vous
assure que oui oui
aujourd'hui on connaîtrait
celui qui m'a mis le coup de badge ça
évite je l'ai pas vu vu que lui il a
toujours été loin devant et lui je le
reconnaîtrai pas parce que j'ai pas
enfin j'ai des petites images mais vous
voyez c'est flou vraiment il y a pas de
caméra de surveillance dans le coin rien
Vival
enfin il y a l'enquête qui est en cours
après je sais pas j'ai confiance en la
gendarmerie qui va falloir nécessaire
mais normalement il y a une caméra vous
aviez vous aviez une assurance oui oui
enfin j'avais une assurance comment on
dit civile enfin pour la montre pour
l'instant c'est toi la c'est mort parce
qu'en fait
[Musique]
si on me la vole en cambriolage à la
maison mais en fait dans la rue non en
fait j'ai l'assurance enfin pour les
dommages qu'on m'a causé mais enfin la
montre c'est c'est tout perdu quoi
votre papa il arrive avec nous
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
un papa quand vous avez vu votre fils à
terre en train de se faire taper avec
une batte de baseball ça a dû être une
image mais terrible j'ai eu peur j'ai
dit bah il va il va le tuer
c'est quoi c'est un traumatisme ouais ça
choque quoi surtout qu'après donc j'ai
je suis allé vers lui et il était KO
quoi donc après on a vite tapé les
pompiers aujourd'hui je sais que ce qui
vous a étonné c'est de vous faire
agresser dans un petit village
exactement j'aurais jamais pensé mais
vous pensez que c'est des gens qui
viennent qui viennent d'ailleurs qui
sont nus qui c'est un réseau voilà qui
qui parce que c'est vrai que les montres
en ce moment de luxe c'est devenu
incroyable ça veut dire qu'il y a très
peu de gens maintenant qui mettent des
mondes de luxe c'est vrai que c'est il y
a vraiment des réseaux qui tournent et
qui ah voilà l'arracher ou bien qui
suivent des gens ou qui viennent
directement même chez vous et c'est vrai
que là d'abord mis la montre sur
leboncoin peut-être que c'est un réseau
et des personnes qui sont venues voilà
qui c'est qui viennent d'ailleurs
c'était pas des personnes de très très
loin bah oui au minimum enfin au plus
loin que c'était Rhône-Alpes mais pour
moi ça reste entre Isère et Rhône pour
moi c'était pas vraiment la région
aujourd'hui vous avez surtout tous les
deux vous dites vous avez un coup de
gueule contre l'insécurité exactement
parce que en fait
la sécurité on sait qu'elle est présente
mais en fait je me serais jamais douté
enfin non on s'en rend compte mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que même dans les
petits villages c'est il y a de
l'insécurité donc des fois j'entends des
ministres dire c'est un sentiment
d'insécurité mais concrètement non enfin
c'est une réalité la preuve demain je
vais me faire opérer du nez parce qu'on
m'a fracasser à coup de baseball quoi
concrètement c'est moi voilà c'est voilà
comme j'ai dit moi enfin venir à la télé
concrètement je m'en fous c'est bien sûr
but moi le but c'était de financer mon
mariage maintenant je me retrouve voilà
donc enfin voilà
ça va coûter à peu près dans les 20000
euros c'est ça donc la montre financée
exactement voilà une grosse partie du
mariage Fabrice vous êtes le père de
Sébastien si vous nous rejoignez
Sébastien qui a été victime d'une
agression et d'un vol et on lui a volé
sa montre aujourd'hui vous
que comme Sébastien vous dites
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible de vivre
des choses comme ça ouais c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué surtout pour
moi c'est pas des des gens qui étaient
ils étaient pas organisés c'est ça ils
ont couru après dans les dans l'herbe
dans la forêt ils avaient même pas de
voiture donc c'est bizarre quoi ils sont
partis après ils sont pas ils ont pris
une voiture après quand ils sont pas à
savoir parce que pareil tous les gens
qu'on a voulu arrêter il y a pas grand
monde enfin il y a quasi personne qui a
qu'une voiture le couple avec les deux
enfants il m'a dit je vais essayer de
les tous les autres personnes et
personne n'a voulu s'arrêter pour nous
emmener en voiture tout ça des voitures
sont passées j'étais chaos par terre ils
sont paraît-il personne s'est arrêté
pour vous bah non personne vous est venu
en aide il y avait des gens qui étaient
autour qui voyaient la scène non
quand je cours après la personne le
réflexe que j'ai eu c'était de sonner à
des interphone pour essayer de faire le
plus de bruit possible et en fait il y a
personne qui est sorti il y a personne
[Musique]
concrètement oui on a laissé
aujourd'hui c'est un traumatisme pour
vous bien sûr
aujourd'hui vous êtes le seul sourire
que j'ai en fait c'est de revoir mes
enfants c'est le seul voilà c'est ce
concrètement quand vous êtes dit je vais
en fait quand ils ont dit à chef-le j'ai
pensé à mes enfants j'ai dit je peux pas
en rester là c'est impossible j'ai dit
concrètement je peux pas
donc on est où ça avance l'enquête ou
pas sans donner d'information bien
entendu en fait ils sont très vague il a
tourné ce matin
ça va faire
j'ai confiance en la gendarmerie il faut
faire pleinement confiance moi ce que je
veux juste c'est qu'ils arrivent à les
attraper et surtout ça auront la
possibilité des attraper après la
justice escale fera son travail ça sera
différent mais en tout cas moi je fais
mon maximum
j'ai donné le maximum d'informations à
la gendarmerie et je pense qu'ils sont
compétents pour arriver à les retrouver
alors le vol est puni de 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amende mais là c'est en bonne organisé
normalement parce qu'ils étaient deux
donc peut-être plus il y a eu des
violences après et entraîné une
incapacité totale de travail donc Gilles
c'est
ils peuvent risquer très gros alors j'ai
eu un policier qui s'occupe de ça ils
sont à deux c'est de plus en plus
violent donc quand vous dites j'ai
entendu HF le
effectivement les policiers me disent
ils sont prêts à mutiler gravement voir
plus à tuer pour ça absolument voilà moi
j'avais aussi donné un interview pour
cnews enfin une interview et qui l'ont
pas dit mais clairement aussi mais les
premiers mots qu'il a dit c'était plante
le plante le et c'est pour ça que moi en
fait quand je me réveille dans dans le
SAMU j'ai une douleur à l'abdomen pour
moi il m'avait planté concrètement j'ai
dit je me suis fait planter pour une
montre et donc en fait la tactique c'est
d'être à deux le premier n'est pas connu
celui qui vole n'est pas connu des
services de police donc après c'est très
difficile de l'identifier même avec
votre portrait robot et le deuxième le
complice en général est un malfrat plus
expérimenté qui va taper être un recours
dans d'autres passions voilà donc c'est
d'une violence terrible et ça explose en
ce moment bijou et montre en France
c'est ça sur les Mathieu je sais que
tu disais à la fois que tu mets plus de
monde c'est fini plus du tout et je
crois plus personne moi j'en ai plus
qu'une elle est dans une elle est même
pas chez moi elle est à la banque dans
un coffre bon bah tant mieux c'est pour
la valeur mais je peux plus rien en
faire alors que c'est effectivement
comme Monsieur moi je suis passionné de
ça l'horlogerie donc c'était un plaisir
de gamin et tout ça voilà c'est
impossible après effectivement est-ce
que des résultats à Paris c'est
extrêmement répandu plus personne n'y
touche et la police m'a dit la même
chose exactement elle me dit aujourd'hui
avant on frapper quelqu'un
maintenant ne frappe plus quelqu'un on
le tue non mais je sais très bien
c'était sur la Côte d'Azur à Nice je la
mettais pas parce que je savais que Nice
Cannes c'était des lieux où enfin
j'avais pris mes précautions sur ça mais
j'aurais jamais pensé enfin voilà comme
vous avez dit c'était combien 2000
habitants la commune sur c'est vraiment
enfin c'est et la police dit aussi ne
mettez pas de fausse du coup dans Paris
bien sûr parce qu'ils y connaissent rien
et vous tapotant Sébastien Fabrice on
espère en tout cas qu'on va retrouver
aux agresseurs et que vous allez pouvoir
vous marier quand même
ça va être compliqué mais je vais on va
faire au mieux on va essayer on va
essayer de voir ça on va essayer de vous
aider aussi pour le mariage on va voir
ce que j'aime pas vous trouver des des
partenaires pour vous aider sur le
mariage ça serait ça serait pas mal
c'est pourquoi le mariage le 1er juillet
on a le temps on va s'organiser on va le
faire ce mariage t'inquiète pas on va le
faire d'accord ah on va on va on va on
va vous aider là-dessus merci à vous
deux